I'm of
neurologists which means I'm interested
in how psychological
immune system how those factors get
under the skin to influence immunity and
what the implications of that immune
changes are for susceptibility to
disease in the case of stress and colds
we've identified a biological process
that's probably responsible and that
it's an immune process and it has to do
with the production of molecule called
its cytokine and there's a particular
type of cytokine called pro-inflammatory
cytokine and these cytokines go to areas
that have been infected or otherwise
damaged and they start the immune
process pro-inflammatory cytokines in
doing their job also caiafa if you want
kind of side effects they actually
create the symptoms of a cold what we
found is that stress interferes with the
regulation of pro-inflammatory cytokines
when people are in distress that they
actually they produce the
pro-inflammatory cytokine they're
responding their immune system is
responding to the cold but it isn't well
regulated and they produce too much of
it and while they eventually do get rid
of the virus in the meantime they're
experiencing much more severe symptom
ontology than men people who are under
low lower levels of stress
you